Regarding the radiation drops following a CAT scan, I have half a model of drops left.
Should I order another?
And is the dosage just a few drops a day?
Last week you'd ever got to the dosage part, just that I don't need to take them beforehand
and to finish the model.
So just follow the dosage that's right on the model.
So I think it's, you know, if it's the drops from us, it's the three drops twice a day.
If it's the radaline from professional health products, I think it's 30 drops twice
a day.
If a mistake and just follow the dosage that's on the model, and then I have made mention
that you just finish the model.
So if you have a half a model left from a previous scan, that's what you're saying, then could
you just finish that half a model, maybe, you know, maybe, I mean, in truth, I mean,
you could take the radion, anybody, even if you've never had radiation, could take the
radiation drops because you're exposed to radiation.
So well, how am I exposed to radiation?
I haven't gotten the next, right?
I haven't gotten, you know, the PET scan, I haven't gotten the CT scan, there's radiation
everywhere.
You're being exposed to radiation.
So you could benefit from taking the radiation, holy, PET, even if you didn't do those type
of therapies or scans.
So I'm just trying to prevent you, anybody from having to take too many things, but to,
you know, to make sure you're doing the best to help rid your body of that, and then by
all means get another model and finish, you know, a model and a half.
So it's just going to help with that.
There's no magic spot in where you're, you know, you're ever going to be completely clean.
So you do your best, the best you can.